nach den gesprächen in berlin und vor
dem treffen mit seinem russischen
amtskollegen morgen in genf begrüße ich
jetzt den amerikanischen außenminister
anthony blinken beim secretary
guten abend schön dass ich zuallererst
wie groß schätzen sie die gefahr eines
russischen einmarsch in die ukraine
heute abend ein
ist ein hohes risiko
russland hat dann der grenze zur ukraine
signifikante zahl an soldaten
zusammengezogen 100000 soldaten und
nicht nur in ukraine sondern unlängst
sich auch soldaten nach belarus
geschickt worden das ist also ein echtes
risiko und das ist nicht nur die
tatsache dass dort truppen
zusammengezogen worden sind sondern auch
unglücklicherweise weil russland das
2014 schon einmal gemacht hat als die
krim annektiert wurde und als die kräfte
in den osten der ukraine entsandt worden
sind das heißt wir müssen uns dort im
augenblick sehr stark darauf
konzentrieren und gleichzeitig ist es
ehrlicherweise so dass nur präsent putin
wirklich sagen kann was man vorhat sie
treffen nun seinen außenminister sergei
lavrov morgen in genf auf neutralem
boden was ist ihre hauptbotschaft anlass
meine hauptbotschaft ist dass wir und
wenn ich hier sage dann meine ich nicht
nur die vereinigten staaten sondern auch
europa und die nato und die eu die
g7-länder alle die
sehr sehr eng miteinander koordiniert
und kommuniziert haben dass wir alle
eigentlich zwei verschiedene sehen dass
diese wege heraus sehen und vorschlagen
die von russland ja herbeigeführt worden
die eine den weg führt eher diplomatie
und dialog wo wir gemeinsam versuchen
die bedenken anzusprechen die wir alle
teilen über die sicherheit in europa und
der andere weg wenn russland den wählen
sollte besteht in einer konfrontation
mit entsprechenden konsequenzen massiven
konsequenzen für russland hinsichtlich
der reaktionen unserer länder und ich
werde den außenministern la france sehen
aber ich war auch in pittsburgh in
berlin wo ich auch nicht nur mit unseren
deutschen partnern zusammen setzen
konnte sondern auch mit den anderen
partner in frankreich und großbritannien
konsequenzen sagen sie präsident biden
hat gestern zunächst gesagt das ist bei
einem kleineren eindringen russlands in
die ukraine nur zu begrenzten reaktionen
der nato käme das jetzt korrigiert aber
zur klarstellung wo ist die
amerikanische rote linie
es ist nicht so sehr eine frage einer
roten linie und wenn wir über
konsequenzen reden dann sind das
übrigens nicht nur die vereinigten
staaten die diese ankündigen wir haben
entsprechende ankündigungen auch von den
g7 das sind also die führenden
demokratischen wirtschaftsräume der welt
aber auch der eu und der nato dass das
neben droht nämlich massive konsequenzen
falls russland gegen ukraine vorgeht und
wenn ein russischer soldat über die
grenze in die ukraine eindringt gefahr
und dann haben wir es mit einem
wirklichen profunden problem zu tun denn
das ist ein ganz klarer angriff auf die
ukraine ob es sich nun um einen oder um
1000 soldaten handelt was der präsident
jedoch gestern meinte war dass er
sich auf szenarien bezogen hat die eben
nicht so weitgehend dass russische
kräfte in die ukraine einmarschieren das
könnte sehr ähnliche auswirkungen haben
wie russland da vorgehen wollen könnte
wie beispielsweise wenn es darum geht
einen staatsstreich herbeizuführen der
die regierung beiseite legte mithilfe
hybrider methoden oder mit anderen
sondereinsätzen die nicht so einfach
erkennbar sind aber was wir in enger
koordination schon seit vielen wochen
bearbeiten besteht darin dass wir
sicherstellen wollen dass für alle diese
szenarien für alle diese aktivitäten
dann auch russland eben im falle einer
aggression gegen die ukraine dass wir
alle gemeinsam die vereinigten staaten
und europa wir koordiniert sind dass wir
einen plan haben wie wir effektiv mit
diesen szenarien also für alle diese
szenarien höre ich daraus werden sie
labeouf in irgendeiner form
sicherheitsgarantien geben versprechen
geben und russland damit entgegenkommen
wir haben bereits ein entgegenkommen
gezeigt nicht nur in den vergangen
wochen sondern schon über viele jahre
hinweg und zwar durchgängig wir haben
immer wieder betont dass wir russland
gegenüber offen sind dann mit russland
auch zusammenarbeiten wollen den russen
und konzentriert seine energien seine
ressourcen und sein talent nicht mal das
ist eine großartige nation und wir
müssen in vielen bereichen
zusammenarbeiten es geht hier nur als
unsere bürger ob wir über den
klimawandel sprechen über coby die
auswirkungen neuer technologien in all
diesen bereichen würden wir wirklich
gerne mit russland zusammenarbeiten und
über viele jahre hinweg hat die nato die
hand ausgestreckt neben transparent und
positive beziehungen zu knüpfen
unglücklicherweise sind wir immer wieder
zurückgewiesen wurden und tatsächlich
ist es so dass das in den vergangenen
jahren so war das nicht die nato das
problem war denn wir sind ein
verteidigungsbündnis
das ist transparent ist und freiwillig
in der mitglied struktur sondern dass
russland eben die ukraine angegriffen
hat georgien angerissen hat dass es dort
der militärische kräfte in moldau gibt
und russland hat deswegen eine große
herausforderung für die europäische
sicherheit dargestellt wir würden gern
einen stabilen und feuer sagt bacher
beziehungen mit russland entwickeln und
präsident biden hat das auch präsident
mutigen direkte mitgeteilt und es gibt
bereiche wo wir zusammenarbeiten können
aber es hängt auch sehr davon ab was
russland tut oder lässt was erwarten sie
in diesem prozess nun von den europäern
was von deutschland konkret gefragt
sollte auch deutschland waffen liefern
jedes land trifft die eigenen
entscheidungen darüber wie
partner ländern wie der ukraine hilfe
angeboten wird im falle der vereinigten
staaten haben wir defensives
militärmaterial schon seit jahren an die
ukraine geliefert und können das auch
weiterhin tun
aber es zeigt auch noch einmal sehr
deutlich welche ja fast schon ironie in
dieser situation liegt
denken sie mal darüber nach die
aktivitäten russlands waren es die im
laufe der jahre eigentlich dazu geführt
haben was putin eigentlich immer
vermeiden wollte bevor russland die krim
annektiert hat und im jahr 2014 in die
ost ukraine einmarschiert ist war die
zustimmung zur nato in der ukraine bei
25% jetzt liegt sie bei 60 prozent die
nato hat ihre ostgrenzen erst als
ergebnis der russischen aggression
verstärkt und bei der frage des defensiv
materials das an die ukraine geliefert
wird das ist erst nach 2014 geschehen
als reaktion und antwort auf die
russische aggression damit die ukraine
sich verteidigen kann die verschiedenen
länder helfen der ukraine verschiedene
arten und weisen sie akzeptieren aber
der ist deutschland auf seine geschichte
verweist und keine waffen liefert
ich sage es noch einmal das sind
souveräne entscheidungen die unseren
verbündeten und partner selber treffen
wie sie unterstützung anbieten wollen
aber was ganz klar ist ist folgendes wir
wie groß ist sind
tatsächlich so eng wie nur möglich hat
seine bei der koordination und bei der
zusammenarbeit wenn es um die
herausforderung von bussen gegenüber der
ukraine gehen und ich kann mich in
meiner eigenen lebenserfahrung nicht
daran erinnert dass wir längere
konsultationen und zu größeren oder
wichtigen den händen gehabt hätten als
unsere gemeinsame sicherheit angeht in
diesem punkt könnten wir nicht enger
zusammenarbeit sie haben gerade mit
bundeskanzler scholz gesprochen der die
pipeline nord stream 2 als ein
privatwirtschaftliches projekt
bezeichnet hat haben sie ihm das
ausgeredet
depression erst einmal war es mir eine
ehre und auch ein gebäude zeit mit dem
kanzler verbringen dürfen wir haben sehr
produktive und sehr durchdachte
gespräche zu ganz vielen verschiedenen
themen gehabt und haben uns über vieles
ausgetauscht aber was wir auch wissen
ist dass jen ist um die herausforderung
unserer zeit geht wie wird damit immer
gehen nämlich in einer partnerschaft in
einem bündnis und in den multilateralen
organisationen dann sind deutschland und
die usa wirklich voll miteinander an der
gleichen richtung ausgerichtet und in
der in den vereinigten staaten wissen
wir dass wir keinen besseren partner als
deutschland haben können und bei der
noch stören dieses weiblein da sind
unsere landes sich an ansichten schon
seit langem bekannt aus dabei und wir
sind gegen den inbetriebnahme dieser
pipeline aber ich habe den kanzler auch
erst unlängst ein paar tagen erst gehört
dass im falle einer russischen
aggression entgegen die ukraine schwer
wie und die kosten zu tragen und das
alles auf dem tisch ist verhandelbar und
natürlich haben die feindlichen staaten
und deutschland im letzten sommer als
kanzlerin merkel im amt war sich darauf
geeinigt welche gemeinsame strategien
wir für die energiesicherheit und auch
die in die sicherheit der ukraine
verfolgen aber wir haben uns auch
verpflichtet das energie lieferungen von
russland nicht als waffe verwendet
werden sollen und dürfen und ich weiß
dass der kanzler auch diese
verpflichtung noch einmal bekräftigt hat
wo stehen wir morgen abend nach ihrem
gespräch mit labor im besten fall was
kann
ich erwarte jetzt erst einmal keinen
großen durchbruch
aber wir haben in der jüngeren
vergangenheit
viele intensive gespräche gehabt mit
russland in unserem stall fix
stabilitäts dialog zwischen den usa und
russland direkt dann im
nato-russland-rat
und dann auch beispielsweise im rahmen
der oecd schätzt jetzt haben wir die
gelegenheit gehabt darüber nachzudenken
was wir dort gehört haben und ich glaube
auch dass große stehtische team hat eine
gelegenheit gehabt sich mit präsident
putin zu beraten wir haben die
gelegenheit gehabt uns zu behalten auch
unter den verbündeten und partnern und
das ist jetzt ein wichtiger augenblick
um erst einmal eine bestandsaufnahme
außenminister lavrov zu erheben um zu
sehen welche schlüsse russland aus
diesen diplomatischen gesprächen zieht
und das wird dann auch russland ganz
klar aufzeigen was unsere positionen
sind und die position unserer
verbündeten und partner denn wir
sprechen mit einer stimme und um auch
herauszufinden ob wir weiterhin den
diplomatischen pfad zur lösung dieser
krise bestreiten können das ist die
frage und wir werden morgen hoffentlich
dann mehr darüber wissen und wir werden
auch herausfinden ob großen und wirklich
ein interesse daran hat diese
differenzen durch einen dialog und
diplomatisch zu lösen oder nicht in
jedem falle sind wir bereit und wir sind
gemeinsam unterliegt der amerikanische
haus minister im zdf heute journal
herzlichen dank danke schön ist dass die
kriterien nach berlin
vielen dank